I'm vici Legend and human unicorn Noah
Lucas we're living through the tech lash
but now it's time for tech to lash back
tech needs an advocate to showcase the
innovators that are changing the world
and reshaping the market in defiance of
the demagogues if I could make an app
that could end all racism and also scale
and be profitable I would absolutely
make it paying for sex is illegal paying
for consent is innovation this is a
revolution of course people are going to
die on my podcast you'll hear their
stories and I'll give their founders my
expert advice on how to land that
billion-dollar valuation you have to
start suing your users innovation is a
zero-sum game and whether you're a
hacker a founder or a legacy player
being left behind I've got what you need
to play smarter